und wir gehen an die Front so sieht er
aus der Krieg mitten im Wald im
Nordosten der Ukraine spielen sich diese
Bilder hier ab wir laufen mit mit einem
ukrainischen Soldaten
[Applaus]
der dort im Wald versucht seine Heimat
zurück zu erkennen
und so sieht das aus Rennen schießen
nicht wissen wo der Feind wo der Tod
lauert
fakt ist die Russen die ziehen sich dort
aus strategisch wichtigen Orten zurück
dort wo der Kampf so aussieht
sprach in der Nacht von geländegewinnen
von 6000 Quadratkilometern
und genau dort im einst umkämpften Krake
im Osten der Ukraine ist jetzt Paul
Ronzheimer live aus der Ukraine Paul
ronsheimer schönen guten Tag dir Paul
wie schreitet die Rückeroberung voran
die Rückeroberung ist absolut
erfolgreich bislang Patricia muss man
sagen und auch die Befürchtung dass die
Russen diese Gebiete du sparst von
diesen 6000 Quadratkilometern dass diese
zurückerobert werden könnten von
Russland diese Sorge aus ukrainischer
Sicht hat sich nicht erfüllt denn
offenbar ist Russland nicht mehr in der
Lage dazu mit den Truppen die man hier
hat mit dem Personal dass man
ursprünglich in die Ukraine geschickt
hat wirklich Gelände Gewinne zu machen
das heißt der Rückzug ist momentan de
facto da zumindest hier in der Region
rund um Raki und auch in isum eine
andere wichtige strategische Stadt
könnte das passieren so heißt es da wird
mittlerweile darüber spekuliert dass die
Russen dort aufgeben können
und jetzt steigt auch der Druck auf den
Kanzler Paul es gibt immer mehr
Regierungsmitglieder die jetzt Panzer in
die Ukraine liefern wollen Panzer die
dort dringend benötigt werden der Druck
steigt auch aus den USA große Frage also
glaubst du dass der Kanzler bald
einknicken wird glaubst du dass es zu
einer panzerwände kommt
Olaf Scholz ist bislang in den
vergangenen Monaten immer stur geblieben
auch dann wenn die Opposition wenn
eigene regierungsminister oder wenn der
Druck hier aus der Ukraine kam von daher
ist davon auszugehen dass das ganze noch
eine Weile dauern könnte man schaut da
sehr auf die USA du sprichst es an dass
es dort die Forderung der USA gab dass
sich Deutschland mehr einmischen solle
mehr tun solle das hat auch die
US-Botschafter in einem Interview am
Wochenende relativ deutlich gemacht und
gleichzeitig gibt es in der
Bundesregierung gerade bei grünen
Ministern und auch bei der FDP doch die
Bereitschaft zu sagen wir senden Leopard
Panzer wir senden also Kampfpanzer hier
in die Ukraine ich gehe davon aus dass
wenn die Wände passiert ist noch dauernd
würde denn der Kanzler macht das nicht
von einem Tag auf den anderen und ändert
seine Position es hat auch in der
Vergangenheit lange gedauert aber diese
Zeit die hat die Ukraine eben nicht und
das sagen die Ukraine auch ganz klar
dass sie diese Panzer jetzt brauchen
jetzt ist die Offensive jetzt ist die
Zeit und ich habe gestern mit dem
präsidentenberater podolog sprechen
können also der engste Mann an der Seite
von selensky und der ist richtig wütend
mal wieder auf Deutschland das also die
Reaktion seitens der Ukraine dass man
hier immer noch zögert dass man hier
teilweise immer noch blockiert was
meinst du was bedeutet dieses Momentum
jetzt diese Rückeroberung gewisser
Gebiete für den weiteren Verlauf des
Krieges silence gesagt er auch das
könnte ganz entscheidend sein wie jetzt
die nächsten 90 Tage ablaufen was also
braucht die Ukraine wie könnte es sich
dort weiterentwickeln
das könnte der Wendepunkt sein Patricia
mit der Betonung auf könnte denn keiner
weiß wie Vladimir Putin wirklich
reagiert wenn er weitere Truppen
reinschicken will in die Ukraine dann
müsste eigentlich eine general mobil
machen
davor hat er in der Vergangenheit immer
zurückgeschreckt denn das würde bedeuten
dass man eben die große Gesellschaft die
durchschnittliche Gesellschaft sozusagen
in diesen Krieg mit reinzieht bislang
hat man immer rekrutiert ins
ausgelegenen Regionen Dörfern aber dann
wäre Moskau St Petersburg betroffen und
das möchte er unbedingt verhindern also
die Frage ist vor allem wie reagiert er
da gibt es mehrere Möglichkeiten aus
Putins Sicht allerdings so scheint es
momentan ist dass er keine Truppen
nachschicken will wenn er das nicht tut
dann hat die Ukraine alle Chancen hier
tatsächlich den Krieg insoweit zu
gewinnen dass man viele Gebiete in die
Russland seit Ende Februar Anfang März
gehalten hat so wie er auch rund um Raki
nicht die Stadt selbst aber
Religion diese tatsächlich zurückerobern
kann Paul ronsheimer live aus Krake
vielen herzlichen Dank für deine
Einschätzungen Paul
[Musik]